في مئه يوم من الحكم لم يمر يوم من الهدوء
على حكومه ريشيسوناك اضراب هو الاضخم منذ
عقد لنقابات النقل والتعليم والخدمه
المدنيه تله اضراب شامل للسائق القطارات
في انجلترا وجزئي لسائق البصات في لندن
واضراب اساتذه المدارس في اسكتلندا عمليه
شد وجذب بين النقابات والحكومه
ممتده منذ اشهر هم يريدون المفاوضات عبر
الاعلام فنقول لهم ما نريد ثم ياخذون
اسابيع للعوده الينا لكننا لا نتصرف بهذه
الطريقه
عبر المئه يوم في رئاسه الحكومه قتل
خلالها على اكثر من جبهه غير الاضرابات
والنقابات فاقاله رئيس حزب المحافظين ناظم
زهاوي صفعه للحكومه
ضعفوا سوناك بحسب المعارضه هو سبب تردده
في اقاله دومين كراب نائب رئيس الحكومه
المتهم بالتنمر
دور المعارضه هو الضغط على الحكومه
ومساءلتها في الشارده والوارده ولكن ما هو
راي الشارع البريطاني في اداء حكومه سوناك
اعتقد انه لا يزال من المبكر الحكم لكن مع
الاخذ بالاعتبار ان لزيتريس كانت كارثه
فان اي شيء قد يكون افضل من ذلك
اعتقد انهم يحاولون فعل افضل ما يستطيعون
للبلد لكن البلد لديها مشاكل كثيره موروثه
تراكمت خلال السنوات العشر الاخيره وهناك
مشاكل كبيره ستتغلب عليها البلاد
اعتقد ان البلد تدار من قبل الاغنياء
ولمصلحه الاغنياء
سبق هذا كله استقاله الوزير غابن ويليامسن
الى جانب الجدل الذي اثير بعد تعيين وزيره
للداخليه والتي اقيلت لخرقها القواعد
الوزاريه اذا اول مئه يوم في حكومه سوناك
كان عنوانها الصمود من لندن لما مكتب
العربيه